by describe it as having bubblegum and
once it's lost all its flavor you have
just a piece of rubber that you chew
over and over again that is essentially
what food is like for me when I put food
into my mouth my name is agent Malik and
I have lost my sense of taste I suffered
a cold and I started getting a metallic
taste in my mouth
once that finally left took my sense of
taste with it it took me a few weeks to
actually identify that it was my taste
because I could smell perfectly I only
eat foods now which spend very little
time in the mouth because I don't
extract any flavor the idea of a
chocolate bar or a steak the way you
chew it in order to bring out the juices
and the flavors of it there's no
enjoyment from it so I find myself
eating very light foods like salads and
rice and also I used the advantage of
adding herbes in order to make the smell
sensation quite enjoyable I also find
these spice very important spicy is not
actually something you taste it's
something you feel it gives us that sort
of tingle in my map you end up with a
rather peculiar eating pattern that
people look at you funny because you're
putting chilies on your breakfast cereal
and you've put in a a mustard sauce I'm
pretty much a lot of the food you eat
and almost three years now we're still
none otherwise rooster why it's gone or
getting my sense of taste back